a clash of Silicon Valley titans ended
with an unexpected settlement Google's
parent company was suing ride-sharing
giant uber for allegedly stealing its
self-driving vehicle trade secrets but
shortly after lawyers entered a San
Francisco courtroom Friday for day five
of the trial it all came to a sudden end
John Blackstone has been following the
case in the battle to dominate the
future of self-driving cars uber and
Google were on a collision course until
the brakes slammed on on Friday in a
settlement uber agreed to pay 245
million dollars worth of company stock
to Google's autonomous vehicle corporate
cousin way mo ubers co-founder and
controversial former CEO Travis kalanick
was the star witness in federal court
earlier this week maybe in this case
seeing how Callen Act came in was the
most important thing and once they saw
that they kind of both knew where they
stood in terms of ubers liability or
potential liability uber agreed that it
would not incorporate way most
confidential information or technology
into its own self-driving cars in a
statement Uber's current CEO said we are
taking steps with way mo to ensure our
software represents just our good work
Travis kalanick released his own defiant
statement no trade secrets ever came to
uber and had the trial proceeded to its
conclusion it's clear uber would have
prevailed a way most folks person said
we are committed to working with uber to
make sure that each company develops its
own technology I think this case was bad
publicity for both of them and they
wanted out of it as fast as possible and
probably would have liked to have
avoided the trial altogether at stake
was a leading role in the market for
self-driving cars that can now move out
of the courtroom and back in the road
for CBS this morning Saturday John
Blackstone San Francisco
self-driving cars there's our future
gonna be a lot of litigation about
around that a lot of new technology bump
out of this road yes